write about that in the book and it's um
it i don't know if it's inspired but
cover that whole period in in his life
anyone else or we'll
take one more if there's one
we good
thank you all very much appreciate it
[Applause]
douglas brinkley is the author of parish
priest father michael mcgivney and
american catholicism
for more information on father mcgivney
visit fathermcgivney.org
michael gordon is chief military
correspondent for the new york times
bernard traynor is an nbc military
analyst
cobra ii is their new book about the
iraq war which they spoke about thursday
at the center for strategic and
international studies in washington
during this hour 15-minute event you'll
also hear commentary on the book from a
panel of foreign
ladies and gentlemen welcome my name is
kurt campbell here at the center for
strategic and international studies i
want to warmly welcome all of you to the
book launch at csis of cobra2 and it was
really our pleasure to be able to uh
really launch this important book into
the world uh we had the great pleasure
and good fortune of having michael
gordon with us at csis for almost two
years and i've worked with general
trainer for many many years both at
harvard and subsequently so it's
wonderful to see good people write an
absolutely first class book
i'm not going to spend a lot of time
with introductions i think you these
gentlemen are well known to you but give
you a sense of what the evening is going
to be like they're going to speak
quickly a little bit about the book
michael gordon first and then general
trainer and then we'll take a few
questions from the audience for the both
of them and then we will open it up for
a broader discussion which i'll quickly
and hopefully easily moderate uh with
distinguished uh guest dennis ross
richard falconrath and michael o'hanlon
also well known to all of you about the
book because this is a book selling
event we promise that this will go
quickly and i urge and ask all of you to
appreciate that
both authors will be signing in the back
and so it's great that you're here and
enjoying our uh
our uh
wine and cocktails but please uh
appreciate the hard work that went into
this book and they're all both authors
are prepared to uh write nice things to
you so with that let me ask uh michael
gordon to take the stand just to say a
little bit about the book and uh what he
hopes to accomplish with it
well i think there are
a lot of people here wondered if i would
ever finish this big book and
i think i trashed two offices and went
through
the number of research assistants and
two of my key research assistants that
christopher mann and jeremiah cushman
are sitting right there and without them
we it's absolutely true we never have
made this project work because this was
a lot of work and it was very intense
um the inspiration for this book was
really a book that general trainer and i
did um 10 years ago the generals wore
and that was a
history of
the persian gulf war which we worked on
for three years so in this case i think
we shaved it to about two and a half
and um and we had our goal then at the
time was to
basically tell get to the ground truth
of that war and to put together the
story from the level of the generals to
to the battlefield and put the two
together so we had a bit of a model to
follow for this conflict
and it um
by the
summer of 2002 it was obvious to me that
there was going to be a another war with
iraq and i began
thinking that um you know the general
trainer and i should build in our
contacts and our background and
and follow through and and do
yet another a book on on this conflict i
have to tell you i had no idea what form
the war would take what would happen i
simply knew that it would be deserving
of a book one that followed in the mold
of the general's war and so when i began
thinking about this i um you know i had
a discussion here with kurt we um i
think we talked in the starbucks at the
fairground north metro
i don't think he was interrupted more
than four or five times during that
conversation but
but you know we basically agreed that um
you know that csis
would um sponsor this and that would
that's really what made it possible so
it's thanks to curtin john henry and
then bruce blair uh picked it up with
his institute afterwards which was very
important i think by the time i
approached bruce he had
almost gotten over all the money put
into my chechnya war documentary and he
was ready to to help out with with this
one is um well
now uh cobra ii um
why that sort of clancy-esque name a
cobra ii is actually
the name of the land invasion plan i was
asked by a cabinet level official i
won't say which one what uh what cobra
ii was and i said well it's the name of
the the war plan on for the ground but
and why cobra ii it was um
well because uh
cobra
one was the
general patton's breakout from normandy
third army and the third army was really
the nucleus for the land war command
which oversaw uh the invasion of iraq
and um i was one of a handful of
correspondents embedded there elaine was
also another one sitting right there in
a row and we we were sort of trying to
get a advantage it was a great place to
get a vantage point uh into how the
generals made decisions and also very
importantly the interaction between
washington and the general the generals
on the field because there was a lot of
that
um
and it took another year or two of hard
reporting to dig out a lot of the story
and access the relevant documents but it
gave me a basis
to work from
now
we set out to tell
the story of the whole war and for us
that is not just the policy making
washington as important as that all
seems here was also the battles
themselves and as a correspondent i was
struck by
um you know how little really the
american public knows about a lot of the
fighting in iraq during the march to
baghdad and also how wrong some of the
conceptions were i mean i think a lot of
people think the war was um
kind of a drive to baghdad regime
collapses and then things got hard but
it was hard from the very
very beginning and they were um because
of the nature of the embed process the
fact that it was a fast-moving event the
fact that people were moving on
and and and it was hard to go back and
put it together i think a lot of these
battles really are haven't been well
documented but general trainer and i set
out to to document and recreate a lot of
these battles what really happened in
nassaria what happened in osama well
what happened at the kiffil bridge
um uh you know this was no walk in the
park and there's some people here in
this room who fought in those battles
and they were they were extremely fierce
fights with with against an enemy that
was not really foreseen at the time
um
the
a key question
though that has emerged since the book
came out on on tuesday
is um
people want to know
essentially how we got into our present
predicament and it is a predicament you
know how has it come to pass that a
nation that won such a lightning victory
right in just a matter of weeks took
down saddam's regime
and
defeated
took baghdad is now
really caught in in a very terribly
difficult situation in iraq with well
over a hundred thousand troops uh trying
to keep the lid on a situation
on a nation that's perched on the on the
edge of civil war
um and so
i've
think they're a number there's no one
reason
which explains why this happened
just like in any complicated human
undertaking it's not explained you know
too simplistically i think there are
three or four principal factors
that taken together
have contributed to um
creating this unpleasant situation we we
confront today and i've want to tick
them off and then i'm going to have the
podium to
make trainer and he's going to address
uh sort of the iraqi side of the war and
how the war seemed from iraq as when
they um fought the americans which is a
really fascinating aspect of the
conflict that we're able to get into
thanks to some access to some classified
materials
the
one thing i think i've in my three or
four reasons as to how we got here i
think that uh
one
principal factor is and i know some
people don't agree with this but i think
it's true anyway that i think that in
the design of the war campaign we
essentially fought the last war
and by that i mean the principal enemy
that the united states envisioned on the
march to baghdad was the republican
guard and the basic concept was you beat
the republican guard you take baghdad
um
we win
uh you know
the regime topples and we put in our own
iraqis they run the ministries and we
can get out in a relatively
you know short period oh yeah there'll
be a lingering presence to stabilize the
country but basically we've achieved our
victory i think that
this was partly an intelligence failure
i think
the cia reinforced this
uh view and i think they did a the
american intelligence community
did a very poor job of documenting the
threat in the southern iraq that the
forces actually confronted i think yeah
they placed where all the republican
guard tanks and vehicles were and
where they thought the wmd was it was
supposedly going to hit these forces but
what they really didn't see were the
things that didn't have icons that
weren't observable from outer space or
from airplanes or which was the presence
of thousands of paramilitary fighters in
southern iraq with rpgs and large caches
of arms and you know the basic
image that the agency presented and
american intelligence presented to the
forces our forces before the war was
that uh the southern cities were quote
ours and i've in researching this book
you know uh this the troops were told
they might they should even be parade be
prepared for parades as i think some
people can confirm in this room and not
that they would necessarily happen but
they might happen parades in the honor
of american forces there was even a
scheme at one point to distribute tiny
american flags throughout southern iraq
so they could wave
at the american forces and they could
take a photograph of this and it would
be a big information op
that was sort of
this capitulation scenario that a lot of
people were led to expect
well it didn't happen that way when
american forces crossed into iraq they
were met
really from the very beginning
they're involved in fighting this
irregular foe didn't wear uniforms
decentralized command and control and
nasseria samoa
on the jaff all of these places
and it was a big wake-up call for the
forces but i think the forces adjusted
pretty well to this the army and the
marines
um but they're
still at higher headquarters
by which i mean the department of
defense and the central command
leadership there was a tendency to see
the republican guard is really the sole
principle threat
and to
to really um not to take the full
measure of what was happening on the
battlefield
even then despite these fights against
you know there's a regular
adversary
there was a tendency at centcom and i
think back at the pentagon to say these
guys are just a speed bump they're just
a distraction keep the pedal to the
metal keep going get to baghdad uh the
war will be uh over and i think this was
a um a kind of a fundamental again
misreading of the battlefield and i'll
tell you one consequence that it had uh
as the forces were approaching to
baghdad um uh secretary rumsfeld raised
the issue of quote off-ramping the first
cavalry division raised it rather
insistently
and
you know why do we really need this
division and general franks initially
made the case for it but he eventually
came to the conclusion it wasn't needed
so at a time when our forces are
fighting a foe that we hadn't
anticipated
and
which really had
had not
complete really been defeated so much
has gone to ground and was being
bypassed
the leadership was
reducing the number of forces in the
plan not adding to it
and i think that reflects a a just a
misreading of the situation on the
ground and i have to say there are
people who um warned of this in the
sense that they at least alerted the
leadership that there was a different
type of adversary there there was a
marine intelligence officer in nasseria
who said the fedeen is a threat that's
not going to go away we're bypassing and
we're going to have to deal with them
later well that's not the
kind of a conclusion that came to it at
the higher levels
i think a second major factor that
contributes to the situation we have
today is a basically a um
i would call it a
kind of an aversion to nation building
as an enterprise on the part of the uh
the white house and the bush
administration
uh even before the bush administration
took office i was interviewing
condoleezza rice people like that
they're saying we're not going to do
this clinton-style nation building we're
not going to do this bosnia stuff that's
going to be for the allies we're just
going to do major warfighting it's a
we're going to not get tied down on this
sort of thing well this was a very
prevalent attitude secretary rumsfeld
gave a speech on this a month before the
war called beyond nation building and
the basic uh notion was that in after we
topple uh this regime in baghdad
instead of a long presence with large
number of troops and a kind of an
international civil service to control
things we were going to transfer
responsibility as quickly as possible to
the iraqis
and implications also get out as quickly
as possible
and i think they were partly seduced
into this by their early experience in
afghanistan where they essentially did
this and
kind of got away with it although if you
look at afghanistan today you one might
wonder if there
perhaps uh you know it wouldn't have
been wiser to take the nation-building
problems a little more seriously but i
think this was an inattitude and what it
what it meant was that um
in in looking towards phase four the
postwar operations you know they didn't
really want to resource uh you know what
do we do about the electrical grid what
do we do about the infrastructure and a
lot of people think these are errors of
omission it's like they forgot to do
this or they oh they they didn't get to
it no these are errors of commission
this is a a policy that they had and and
implemented um you know they it's not
like they forgot that there would be a
problem of law and order in baghdad it
was raised by mid-level officials in the
justice department who said we need 5
000 international civilian police and
that issue went to the white house and
the white house said we are not sending
these people we're going to rely on the
iraqi police because we want them to be
in charge that was a perfectly good
strategy on the assumption the iraqi
police were competent and didn't run
away what was the backup plan if if the
iraqi police didn't didn't hold there
there wasn't one
so i think the second factor was an
aversion to um
nation building and a third factor and
then i'm going to hand over to to to
make
that i think made a very difficult
situation
worse was the ill-advised decision by
ambassador bremer to dissolve the iraqi
military and essentially try to run iraq
as the viceroy
of of the country and you know this is a
decision
he has an account of it in his book but
i i find that account is incomplete
uh this is a decision was taken against
really the advice and counsel of the us
military i was with the us military and
they
the plan that they went in with was to
um
basically work with the iraqi army
retrain them keep the iraqi army it's a
plan by the way that was brief to the
president and he thought that was the
plan going in
and used them as a source of provide
security for the country as a source of
labor that was the plan and general
mckiernan with whom i was embedded and
the cia station chief was meeting with
iraqi generals to try to recall them
sure the iraqi army went awol the plan
was to bring them back there was every
indication they were prepared to come
back they came back later for their pay
and that was the plan when ambassador
bremer arrived and with a decision to
disestablish the iraqi army and build a
new one over a very very slow period and
it was a
what the consequence of that is
is having misread the battlefield
and not appreciate the significance of
the fedeen which provided indication
that when baghdad fell
maybe there would be another element out
there that you might have to deal with
and having off-ramp the first cavalry
division there was a limited number of
u.s troops
and then ambassador bremer comes in and
says well it disbands iraqi army we
don't need them
now there is a very limited number of
iraqi troops we have a limited number of
american troops a limited number of
iraqi troops you put the two together
what you really have is a security
vacuum
and it was a perfect environment for an
insurgency to gain traction and grow
and
combined with the nation-building
failures
which left a large segment of the iraqi
population
disillusioned with their liberators
and you know in that summer of 2003 in
that long hot summer
virtually all the military officials i
talked to at the time believed there was
a window of opportunity
to put a rack on a better track i think
there was always going to be resistance
and always going to be more resistance
than we thought going in
but i i think it needn't have been this
sort of virulent resistance and that's
my uh thesis and assertion in the book
and i actually think it's it's a
viewpoint that is subscribed to by uh
the people who were there
uh at senior levels on the ground in
iraq in in the summer of 2003. now at
this point i'm going to turn it over to
general trainer who's going to address
what um the iraqi perspective literally
uh on the war and
the implications of that for um
both the lead up for the war and and the
the conduct of the war itself
thanks michael
[Music]
so kurt thank you very much for the
hospitality of the house
and to all a happy st patrick's day
uh what i'm going to do is
address what i think is one of the
unique parts of our book and probably
one of the more interesting parts
is the view from the other side of the
hill
while we were reading the iraqis or more
correctly while we were misreading the
iraqis
the iraqis were misreading us
we have to start off with the
acknowledgement that most of this
information we were able to glean
from a
classified program that was conducted by
the joint forces command
and put together from the interrogation
reports of the senior leadership
uh of the iraqi political and military
hierarchy and was called iraqi
perspectives and we also drew upon the
the
the studies of the iraqi uh survey group
that looked into the wwmd issue
i suppose we should start off with
with an understanding of sonoma hussein
and everybody knows he was a very nasty
man but i think i would describe him as
an egotist
and like most
tyrants
very secretive
very paranoid and a survivor and
survivor remember that as i go through
this
um
drawing on some of the
pow or epw reports this is way the way
one of the the senior iraqis
described him
saddam hussein
lived an illusion
he was so self-absorbed that he believed
his thoughts were divine
if he thought it it was true and correct
consequently
his thoughts could not be counted with
logic
i think that speaks volumes about the
man
and the consequences of this i think are
pretty much expressed in what tariq aziz
his number two man had to say
saddam
was the absolute ruler and was
responsible for making all the decisions
only his relatives would dare to present
him with even mildly opposing views
of course telling the truth
isn't in your benefit
so you could see
the area in which people operated it was
an area of enormous fear with this
egomaniac
the earliest incident that we came
across of significance that kind of
reflected this thing was a meeting that
he had with his military leaders in 1995
now he'd been defeated in 91 in the
desert storm operation
so they were kind of
doing the rebidding on the part of the
military and they were coming up with
the realization that if you fight an
enemy that's highly advanced such as the
united states you know they stood
absolutely no chance to do this so one
of the proposes was that they would
establish a
uh a people's army people's resistance
and and they drew the lessons that the
from the russians
against the germans in world war ii and
it would the people would resist and it
wouldn't be the the regular armed forces
well this did not set well with saddam
hussein
for two reasons number one
uh he believed or
pretended to believe
that uh that the strategy that was
employed
uh against the americans in the first
gulf war was successful
the strategy of defense in depth
where you just draw back draw your enemy
in and destroy him and said you know the
americans were defeated at the euphrates
lines because no
reasonable person if they were winning
would have stopped at that point they
would have moved right on to baghdad and
overthrown the machine because they
didn't
because they didn't it meant that we
were successful and our military
operations were correct and that
strategy was correct and now you want to
change it so that didn't go over well
with them the second part that disturbed
him was the idea of a people's army of
people rising up
against the invader
well he didn't like that very much
because he saw what happened in 1991
during the fighting that the shia
uprising
nearly toppled the regime
he was shaken to his roots by what
happened
now
what the military was addressing was an
external threat
an invasion from outside
and they really weren't thinking of the
united states
because the principle
external threat from the point of view
of the iranian leadership and saddam
hussein himself
was not the americans it wasn't the
israelis it was the iranians
people right next door three times their
size they had fought an eight-year war
against them and saddam hussein knew
that they had an active
wmd program
that was the external threat
and that was the one that the military
was focusing on
but this was a kind of a use useless
conference because saddam hussein wasn't
focusing exclusively on the iranians
indeed not even principally
he was focusing on as i've said he's a
survivor
he was focusing on the dangers within
iraq
an internal security problem that is
where the threat to the regime came and
he was insistent that they deal with
that now being paranoid he didn't trust
anybody outside of his own
his own tribe and his own family and
even he didn't trust them very much
so he made this concession which is
interesting because it's almost a
paradox with not having a
a people's war against an external
invader
he established in 1994 under uday a
parallel military structure to the
regular army and the republican god
and that was known as the ferrying
saddam's fedine and these were all loyal
sunni and saddam devotees
and
what they would do
would be in place
throughout
iraq particularly in the shia regions to
the south
to put down any sort of insurrection
notwithstanding any sort of external
invasion but just to keep these people
under control so they were established
in all the towns and villages and cities
in southern iraq
and they were armed with caches we all
know all the reports coming from the
from the troops in the in the field with
these enormous caches of
munitions that they found in schools and
hospitals and mosques and so forth but
they were put there none of them heavy
weapons but you know ak-47s machine guns
are rpgs
for these fedeen units that were that
were embedded down there to maintain a
control over the shia population and on
top of that
he put out orders under penalty of death
there would be no bridges blown
and for two reasons number one and of
course as you know the mesopotamian
valley has all these the tigers
euphrates another water water
holes that had to be had be bridged
he did that
for two reasons because he didn't want
to destroy the infrastructure economic
infrastructure of iraq
but most importantly
one of the problems in the first gulf
war was that the bridges had been
destroyed by the americans
and when the
the iraqi armed forces tried to come
down to put down
the insurgency that had broken out in
1991
they were impeded by the because the
bridges were down he didn't want that to
happen again he wanted the bridges to be
in place so that the republican god and
others could rush to the to the scene of
the insurrection and support the fedeen
who were holding holding down the the
uh the the insurrection and then put the
insurrection down completely so we were
concerned in the united states about
them blowing the bridges he had no
intention of blowing the bridges or
blowing the dams or burning up the the
oil fields none of that was in it was in
the game plan and i'll return to to that
in a moment as to
as to why
now the other thing that he
given the fact that he looked at the
external threat as being iran and also
the internal threat being the principle
one being being his own people we come
to the subject of weapons of mass
destruction now he had tolerated 12
years of sanctions which hurt iraq
terribly just virtually destroyed
destroyed the infrastructure
and you say to himself well he didn't
have wmd
why didn't he come clean on that and get
the sanctions lifted
well
he didn't again because of his great
fear of survival of the regime
and he wanted people to worry about
whether he had wmd or not
and he had practiced what
general hamdani who was the commander of
the second corps
described as
deterrence by doubt creating doubt in
everybody's minds as to what exactly he
had and he thought that this was very
useful
for forestalling the iranians
and also for forestalling
any sort of uprising on the part of the
shias because he could always he already
used them against the used wmd against
the kurds and he attempted to use it in
the in the shia uprising
and for x number of reasons uh they it
it didn't happen
but he felt that this was a a great
deterrent to problems external and also
problems problems internal
but he did not have wmd he got rid of it
all
he got rid of it all and it was on the
22nd of december of 2002 just a couple
of months before the war that he called
his military leaders in and told them
that the cupboard was bare that he
didn't have wmd they were shocked
and i remember it's a compartmented and
secret society people didn't know what
was going on
even the leadership and they were
shocked
that we don't have a counter force in
case there's an invasion because the war
clouds of an american invasion
were starting uh to to gather in fact
they were rumbling uh and he said no the
cup is bad we don't we don't have
anything
and
they were absolutely shocked
so
you have to say to yourself well
where is all this evidence coming from
one of the interesting features was
if you recall colin powell stood before
the united nations and he showed
pictures of
biological mobile biological
laboratories and he had tapes of
messages that went back and forth from
signal intelligence telling people you
know to clear up and make sure that
inspectors would come in they wouldn't
find any any any wmd because he wanted
to keep the u.n
on his side and this was interpreted as
hiding wmd but it was just the opposite
that
he was insisting that
the everybody within iraq that was
involved in the original wmd program was
make sure that there was no vestiges
that people
could find or the the
international inspectors could find that
the americans could use as a causes
belly
so there was a misinterpretation on our
part for something that was legitimate
on his part now how did he view the
united states as a threat he didn't
particularly view the united states as a
threat
it fought the war in in 1991 as far as
he was concerned the americans got
everything that they needed you know oil
was flowing they had a presence there in
the middle east uh the united states was
not a principal
exterior threat except in the remotest
sense again the internal threat was his
own people external threat was the
regional threat from iran on top of that
he just wouldn't see could couldn't see
that the united states would go to war
uh against him for a number of reasons
uh one as they say no particular reason
uh to do so from from his point of view
the fact that the united states did not
have any sort of constituency in the
international community that would help
him uh there was um
the uh the fact that the the united
states was casualty adverse
the idea of them going to war and
bleeding he just didn't think the
americans you know could stand uh losses
that would be involved in in the war one
of the reasons we
he was able to stop the americans in in
the first cold war so he had this whole
litany of reasons including the fact
that the international community would
be putting terrific pressure on him and
particularly germany germany and france
which turned out to be the case so he
just did not feel that the united states
would go to war uh but to a certain
degree it would if there was a risk but
then he assessed the risk this way
because of casualty diversion and
the united states high technology if
they did go to war it probably would be
using airplanes and missiles and so
forth and there would be these strikes
and as he took the position hey nobody
knows how to accept the american air
attacks but in the iraqis that's not
going to defeat us
worst case situation was if the
americans did in fact come across the
border and invade iraq they wouldn't go
to baghdad
they would simply settle for the shia
area in the south and particularly the
romania oil fields take control of those
and then then they would stop and as far
as saddam hussein is concerned
he could still survive that as long as
he held on to baghdad and had the
kirchook oil fields in the north he
could he could accept the loss of the
shia territory in the in the south
as long as the americans didn't go any
further so it was it was an amazing
shock when the americans did attack
now
as we know and and michael alluded to
the fact that he made use of of the
fedine
and they were operating under what was
known as the emergency plan they were
not under the military they were under
uday huday hussein
and there was it was a decentralized
organization
and it was not designed to deal
with an invader
as one of the proposals were for the
people's war in the 1995
uh conference no it was it was a counter
insurgency force not an insurgency force
this counter insurgency aimed precisely
at a shia uprising
however the fact is you know if an
invader comes in they weren't going to
sit on on the sidelines they were going
to fight and they did and as michael has
alluded to they became the the biggest
thorn in the side of of our military
operations and be became the core then
not that it was planned we became the
core of what
finally emerged as the the post-sardine
saddam
insurgency
well as the americans advanced
the entire
military
organization started to become unstrung
the attacks were fast air power did
tremendous amount of damage
but the
saddam hussein also inhibited the iraqi
military he's so afraid of a coup not
only by the shias but by his own people
that he kept units they couldn't contact
with one another the iraqi army
republican gods who were supposedly
probably his most loyal troops the
republican god was reduced
to sending out reconnaissance units
which normally in any army go look for
the enemy
the units would look sending their
reconnaissance outfits out to find out
where friendly forces were because they
couldn't communicate with one another it
was a disastrous dysfunctional uh sort
of military the special republican god
which was these were the most foreign
and loyal troops
they had the responsibility for baghdad
no other units could go in there whether
they're republican guard or regular army
special republican god was the only one
that could be in
uh in baghdad but the special republican
god
commander was appointed by saddam
hussein
because he was a cousin and he was
described by his fellow generals
as a man who had
failed the staff college
was a drunk
and a coward
all the requirements that one would have
as being non-threatening to saddam
hussein as one as the secret military
the minister of defense said that he was
too dumb to to create a coup
and too stupid and too afraid to
participate in one so that was the guy
that was in charge of the defense of of
baghdad
as we
continued the attack towards baghdad
overcoming some of the fitting in
opposition
in december
in december saddam hussein suddenly has
this brilliant stroke
that we're going to change our strategy
and we're going to have a circle
strategy with baghdad being the key to
everything he had a whole baghdad and he
was going to have a circle defense and
they come up with an entirely new plan
which uh thanks to uh
some contacts that we have with the with
the germans uh we received that but
an outline or an outlay overlay of that
plan in february of what the defensive
plan so-called circle or ring plan for
baghdad
so i went to tommy frank's in february
so he knew what they
they had planned to do but it didn't
mean anything because it could not be
executed the military was not in a
position to do exactly what what the
ring plan call for but it's an
indication that some of the people who
vocally opposed our
are participating our actions in in iraq
actually uh helped us out but there was
another aspect of it
saddam sane and his his close entourage
remembered schwarzkopf's move in the
first gulf war if you recall it was the
so-called hail mary or or left-wing
attack where we were moving up the
center and all of a sudden we came
around with a left hook and he became
convinced that this is what the
americans ruptured that the attack
coming from the south was not the main
attack
why well there were only two divisions
of marine division and army division
involved in it and he knew that the
fourth infantry division which was the
most advanced of american military
divisions which was the one that was
supposed to come down from turkey in the
north and the turks
prohibited it
where was that that was really the main
attack that the attack from the south
was false and the attack actually would
come from the western desert coming out
of jordan
so at the last minute when there was the
need from an iraqi military perspective
to to reinforce the southwestern front
the euphrates front against the third
mechanized infantry division
coming across through the kavala gap
just when that was essential
to to defend the capital he denies he
denies the the reinforcements and
focuses attention to the west
and what reinforcements in units they
were started to orient themselves orient
themselves to the west not that again
that it made that much difference
because our air power was was decimating
so it was just it was almost
tragic comic
what happened to the to the iraqis
dysfunctional led by a paranoid
not quite a he wasn't a madman but a
paranoid survivor and to the very end he
couldn't believe that he had been
defeated when you saw that fellow from
the
propaganda bob or whatever they called
him talking about whether the americans
aren't there
he really believed it
the reports coming in from the field for
the most part were always positive
because you never gave sodomy saying
erroneous reports it was it was very
similar to what happened with the
germans at the end of world war ii and
hitler you know was moving around
imaginary units and still getting favor
reports from the field
so they were defeated uh hamdani the man
that i mentioned earlier commander of
the second corps of iraqis have faced
the the bulk of the american attack
is absolutely uh distraught over what
had happened when the americans came
across uh busted through at cobbler and
he was out in the when he was up in
baghdad asking for reinforcements and
permission to to blow a very critical
bridge which would snow the americans
down finally got the permission to do it
but it was too late they only partially
brewed the bridge americans were coming
across and
he realized the jig was up when he went
to his field headquarters and he found
that there was an american m1 tank
sitting right outside of it so he gave
up and uh and left and spent ten days in
the wilderness before he finally gave up
to the americans and he estimated that
was only about 15 percent of the iraqi
army that actually fought the americans
but i have to tell you they were 100
percent of the fedeen that fought them
and then we had the insurgency that
followed i think i'll close at that
point if i may
thanks
i think what we'll do is go straight to
some
commentary and then we'll open it up for
questions just so that we we're sure
that we hear from everyone and i think
we'll just go along uh the panel and
what i'd like to do to start off is ask
dennis richard and michael just a couple
of minutes about the book what your
overarching views are and i'd be curious
as you sum up this is clearly a book
that's not done there'll be another
version
probably in a year or two's time year or
two time i'd be curious to hear from
each of you help us write that last
chapter dennis
well first um
this one right yeah
look it's an extraordinary book and i
have to admit i read it right after i
read assassin's gate so i come here
completely depressed
when you read those two books together
it's it has an extraordinary impact on
you
look i think that the
there are some important lessons that
have to be drawn from the book
there have to be i think there has to be
a pretty good assessment
of what was the rumsfeld strategy which
is spelled out in the book not only for
what happens here but in the future
rumsfeld was uh governed as you spell
you you outlined in the book
by a strong conviction that there's been
a revolution in military affairs and it
has to be applied in terms of how you
use force
when you're trying to engage in regime
change
his focus clearly is using
information dominance lethality weapons
precision guidance great mobility and
you don't need to use mass and you
suggest in fact if you're going to deal
with nation building and what comes
afterwards you have to
i think that the next chapter as we look
at other contingencies needs to evaluate
the judgments you make about
the
rumsfeld
commitment to this kind of force
structure and revolution and whether or
not one has to rethink that not only as
it applies
to
uh the kinds of conflicts we're going to
be in but the implications it has for
forced planning
over over time number one number two uh
i think uh the
what you do extremely well is outline
what can only be described as a kind of
faith-based approach to regime change
that everything would fall into place
not fall apart
and
here
i think it's
what would be very good is to highlight
something that you don't quite do in the
book that maybe does fit in the next
book
i think you're very good and michael you
said it it's suggesting that the last
war was fought
but it's also the case that the
the worst case contingencies for after
the war
were also the same ones that were
basically planned against
in other words it was the uh we had to
plan against and prevent the oil fields
from being set on fire
uh i mean i would just say it was the
kuwaiti oil fields that were set on fire
in 91 not the iraqi oil fields that were
set on fire
and because as you note saddam's view
was that he was still going to be there
he wasn't going to destroy his own oil
so
we were planning against something that
was worst case that didn't happen
we planned on refugee flows because
that's what happened in 91 with all the
kurds who went uh you know went to the
north
uh here again we had created a protected
area for the kurds so where were in fact
all these refugees going to be coming
from but here again this is something
we're planning against you're quite
right there was planning done for what
would happen after the war
but if you go through each of the areas
that we're focused on some of them were
legitimate and understandable
some of them may have been legitimate
but not particularly understandable and
unfortunately
the real worst cases which
were the effects of looting
were not dealt with you note that there
were those who said look we need a
police presence
uh we need to plan for this but in
effect they never really get listened to
uh the whole
what happens and i guess for the next
book
the whole question of what happens when
you have a vacuum
if you're gonna if if you
i don't know how often we're gonna be
engaged in these kinds of conflicts in
the future given what's happened with
this one but if you get involved and
you're thinking about regime change
you better think about what happens
once there's a collapse of a regime
as you note there was a key assumption
here that basically everything would
remain in place and all you had to do is
come in and be enablers that was the
rumsfeld view
but in fact
if there's a vacuum what happens then
and how do you deal with the vacuum and
what capabilities do you have and how do
you enhance
capacity and can you do it from the
outside and are we particularly well
equipped to do it from the outside and
if we're not who can
the notion that there would be air
forces that would come in
uh
ignored the view of that most iraqis
have towards their neighbors
how would they have reacted to that i
would guess not particularly well
i guess i won't belabor it there's a
series of assumptions that are made
that obviously
didn't fit the situation and maybe what
that's a reminder of is since i'm doing
a book on stagecraft right now you know
you you start with objectives that may
be that may make sense in the abstract
but objectives always have to be refined
by assessment an assessment has to be
informed by reality
not by a faith-based view of what
reality is
the reality has to be
uh i think
somehow
you create the reality by making sure
that you're listening to people who also
are raising hard questions i'm afraid
one of the consequences one of the
reasons some of the hard questions
weren't raised
is because people raising questions were
seen
as somehow not believing in what the
policy was and therefore if they were
discredited then their questions were
discredited
but those questions also had to be taken
into account
you're not going to be able to face
reality and understand reality if you
deny reality and one of the things that
comes through very clearly in your book
is there's a lot of denial there isn't
acceptance of reality
so if you're going to deal i think if
you're going to get into a situation of
this sort
make sure that you
you incorporate
people who represent a range of views
and you do the kind of war gaming that
i'm impressed by what you described as
the kind of wargaming that was done in
advance you look at the military's plans
and they're quite impressive and the
military is constantly
raising questions about do they have
sufficient forces
i'll close with this the one question i
have
for you
that
i know you tried to answer in the book
but i guess maybe i wasn't completely
satisfied by the answer
why isn't the military more insistent
on this
they can see what the consequences are
not only in terms of
the nature of what has to happen in
terms of getting rid of saddam
but also in terms of what is required
for afterwards in terms of securing the
borders securing all the weapons of mass
destruction sites which after all was
the ostensible reason for going
trying to create order and ensuring that
you have
not a situation of chaos and you have
filled the vacuum in a way that prevents
anybody else
from being able to be
perpetrators of violence michael say
that question for a moment richard uh
having been uh serving at the white
house during this consequential time be
useful to offer your perspectives of
someone who lived through this
i had um
two really big uh puzzles for me uh
watching this experience um in the
government at first you don't really
deal with a book and that's okay but it
was sort of
on the days right after 9 11
how is it that people immediately
started thinking about attacking iraq
and as someone who was sort of a
terrorism specialist it just amazes me
when i hear that because it doesn't it
just doesn't follow and i know that's
not the focus of your book
um
but it comes up in the very first
chapter and it reminded me of the
questions that
that i had
watching that the second though is the
focus of your book
which is why did the post-war
planning and and occupation go so badly
and how is it
that this administration with such an
experienced group of principals
makes so many mistakes and your book
like others
chronicles those mistakes and you do a
particularly good job chronicling them
but i still have questions and this
maybe is the last chapter that kurt's
talking about i still have questions
about why i mean why is it
that uh
this group of people
who were there at the time could make
this series of mistakes and i have i'm
going to just offer three
explanations
which are a little bit different than
the ones that you offer in the epilogue
first i think the
requirements of realistic post-war
planning collided
with the requirements of building
political support for the war
and
political support both within the
administration which is to persuade the
president himself
and there were those who wanted to do
the stretch certainly i can understand
but then the president had to be
persuaded and that took a while he
ultimately was persuaded and once he was
persuaded congress had to be persuaded
and a lot of other countries had to be
persuaded to at least acquiesce
and my hunch is that the process of
doing that
um really argued against being very
candid about how difficult it would be
after the war
and what would need to be done
and dissent
and questions
and hard facts and long studies all were
the sort of thing that could make it
harder to build the political support
you needed to start the operation in the
first place so that would be my first
explanation
um and that was when you say this was
they fought the last war
i don't think that dynamic prevailed in
the last war in
1990 91 to the same extent
i think this was a different dynamic
second point
in uh
how all these mistakes could be made
about the post-war planning in
engineering although the one thing you
don't want to create in a mechanical
system is what they call single point
failure
and i think we had sort of interagency
single point failure here
we had just an extraordinary
concentration
of power in the secretary of defense
without the normal checks and balances
that we expect in a functioning
interagency process and you do chronicle
this pretty well
i thought the uh marginalization of the
joint staff first within the department
of defense
um and their sort of exclusion from some
of the planning process the secretary of
defense's ability to as as tom white put
it grind down the combatant commander
and get him just to sort of shrug and go
along with the preferences the the
marginalization of the national security
council staff
here
and their exclusion from the planning
process
and the marginalization of the secretary
of state
and his subordinates
and so you got to the point where
all the big decisions which were not
you know they weren't strictly military
decisions were really concentrated in
one man
and in a building which he had by then
submitted you know to his will
and so this is the sort of thing that we
really want to guard against in the
future to ensure that when the president
is getting advice
uh on massive major decisions like this
that it reflects the view of all his
advisors
and
that you know power and authority and
information is widely shared among the
people who get it and it seems to me
that wasn't happening uh to the extent
it should have you know goldwater
nichols really reaffirms in law this
notion of unity of command
and that i think is exactly right for
tactical issues and operational issues
in the field but when you get to what is
essentially a political military issue
or to use dennis's word statecraft
unity of command is a problem it's not
that simple you can't have it be quite
that the third point and i don't think
this comes out enough in the book
frankly of why these failures were made
um is
this was objectively a really really
hard task
and i i was impressed frankly with jerry
bremmer's book on this when he just
talks about here's the guy who was
essentially uninvolved
in the war decision and planning shows
up one day and has to take over with a
couple weeks
preparation and he catalogs all of the
problems he has to face
and they're unbelievable i mean it's
astonishing when you think about how
hard this task was
and one of the theses in the book
michael and mick
is i'll read it i was really struck by
it is there is a direct link between the
way the iraq war was planned and the
bitter insurgency the american-led
coalition subsequently confronted and i
think that's right there is a link i
don't deny it but i think there's a
stronger link between the ethnic
geography of iraq and the bitter
insurgency and between the saddam
history in that area and the bitter
insurgency i think if there's any if
there's criticism i'd offer about the
book cause i think it underp it
downplays a little bit
the impact of that history in iraq
and perhaps exaggerate
the
impact of the mistakes we made in the
post-war planning
and occupation effort i don't doubt that
there were mistakes and i don't doubt
that they had a role but their relative
weight as opposed to what was the what
were the facts on the ground when we got
in there i think might have been a
little bit um misplaced last point kurt
there is a sense in this book that um
transformation of the military was
oversold a bit
and and i worry about that i i worry
about taking too much from that clearly
the post-war planning and occupation was
mishandled
but the war itself
uh was a pretty extraordinary event when
you think about it um i mean you take
this you know
we can dismiss them however we want and
i think the information you have about
the iraqi strategy is terrific but this
was the fifth largest army in the world
uh and it was uh defeated effectively in
three weeks
with hardly any air campaign beforehand
with one division less
than even the planners had counted on
because the fourth wasn't available from
turkey
this was a fraction of what the military
conventional wisdom was beforehand it
would have and they did it
and it's pretty extraordinary and it
says a lot
uh i think it validates a lot of the
ideas that were in the president's
citadel speech in 99 and that secretary
rumsfeld carried through
and clearly
those lessons should not have been
carried over into the post-war
occupation when you did need mass
but it was a remarkable success and i
hope that the less that we don't take a
lesson out of this experience which says
that transformation uh uh was a mistake
or was oversold and that we do in fact
continue down that route for our own
defense policy
thank you richard
thanks kurt it's an honor to be here
discussing this brilliant book by two of
the great military historians of
contemporary america and such an
important conflict and it's an honor to
be speaking in front of people who have
been involved in this
been great comments so far and i just
want to add a couple especially given
that i have to admit i haven't finished
the book yet
when i got it monday afternoon i thought
of calling my buddy kurt and saying kurt
there's only one way guys like you and i
can find the time between now and
thursday to read this book which is to
book a flight to japan right now
and just go and then come back
but but uh but i'm delighted it's
actually this thorough and i will look
forward to finishing it in the days
ahead uh because the military history
piece of it is going to be such a big
contribution but i'm going to as others
have talked more about the specifics on
the policy debates uh just make a couple
of observations one in trying to
understand how we could um
how we could make some of the mistakes
that we made uh and
and richard's done a nice job i think of
of reminding us of the successes and the
mentality and the inherent difficulty of
this but still there were some big
mistakes and i like to think of it as
the the the failure to do a good job
starting on april 9th was really the
flip side of the same logic that led us
to such a brilliant success one didn't
have to follow from the other but
rumsfeld fell in love with his war plan
he fell in love with a plan that said go
for the for the head of the serpent cut
it off and the rest of iraqi society
should be intact and should be something
we can work with because i think it was
the right war plan to try for michael
was i think very michael gordon did a
very nice job of saying there needed to
be a plan b
but it makes sense that in such a
corrupt dictatorship that you would try
to go for the head of the serpent and it
made sense given all the cia contacts
and other special forces uh efforts that
we had made to hope the conventional
army might not fight that hard and in
fact we had some success in keeping the
conventional army largely out of this
fight and largely because they didn't
really support the regime for all the
reasons and with all the all the
implications michael had talked about
there were all these multiple layers of
security the conventional army was many
layers removed from saddam not great
loyalty to him uh not part of his inner
circle not permitted inside of baghdad
there was no particular reason to think
they would want to fight and therefore
every reason to hope that maybe just
maybe they would survive the war and be
willing and able to restore security for
us once it was complete once the
invasion was complete so the the same
logic that i think led to this fairly
smart invasion strategy on balance
despite the problems with the fed yin
that uh bernard and michael have talked
about and which are very real um that
same logic
uh led us to believe that
we had figured out a way to minimize the
resistance from iraqi society writ large
and i think that was true but the
problem is you couldn't count on these
institutions surviving and that's
obvious in hindsight it was also fairly
obvious frankly at the time to me and
most others on the outside that you
needed a plan b
uh but i could still see how working so
hard to come up with
this
this this new invasion plan which flew
in the face of a lot of traditional
centcom thinking uh and frankly rumsfeld
did a good job of challenging some
traditional military brute force
concepts of needing a half million
people a lot of the revisions rumsfeld
made in those six to 12 months leading
up to the war or i guess 15 months
leading up to the war we're fairly smart
the problem is he didn't have time to
get into the details like that if he was
going to ignore phase 4 as a result and
there wasn't enough benefit to doing it
to ignore phase 4 as a result but i
think some of the logic of what he was
doing made sense and was validated by
the success of the invasion the problem
is that in doing that working so hard to
do that he sort of became enraptured by
his own plan and uh
believed that it would work in a way
that it only could be viewed as an
aspiration so cutting off the head of
the serpent nice idea uh drive to the
heart quickly um nice idea maybe the
iraqi security forces like the
conventional army will survive good idea
but the huge mistake was counting on
that happening and not having the plan b
that michael gordon talked about so i
think that that was to me that's how i
understand uh in the book
rightly or wrongly if i've understood it
correctly or not has reaffirmed this
thinking in my own head that uh rumsfeld
worked so hard to come up with a very
good first half of the plan that he
became a little infatuated with his own
clever thinking which was pretty clever
but only went up to
the april 9th 2003. um
that's my take on some of the broad
strategy i want to talk a minute about
the fedine in the south and um
i think this to me is one of the big uh
maybe to me this the single most
important new ground the books breaking
so far in in what i've read of it and
what i've read of the broader iraq
literature because we all think of the
iraq insurgency and i think president
bush rightly describes it as having
three main components uh foreign
jihadists
uh former regime elements like the
fedeen and then the fence sitters the
people who weren't necessarily going to
fight but who chose to over time because
things didn't work very well
because they were sort of mistrustful of
us to begin with they were loyal to
their fellow sunnier brethren almost all
these fence sitters are sunni arab
especially since sauder and his forces
have not been fighting as hard since uh
the summer of o4
and a lot of the a lot of the thinking
so far in the iraq debate i would
summarize as saying if we had only
gotten off to a better start the fence
sitters would have stayed on the other
side of the fence they wouldn't have
become so discouraged they wouldn't have
been as frequently unemployed they
wouldn't have been as angry at us for
doing these uh culturally insensitive
cordon and sweep operations or for uh
efforts to put down the insurgency early
on that led to civilian casualties and
bred more resentment a lot of the
literature has done a nice job pointing
out that that group of fence sitters
might have been much smaller if we had
gotten off to a better start in the
immediate post-invasion period
what i think michael and mick have done
in addition to validating that argument
is to talk about the former regime
elements in much more detail with much
more vividness than we have realized up
until now was possible and actually
point out that that group also might
have been diminished in size a great
deal and to me i've always assumed that
the jihadists sort of came later and the
fence sitters were fence sitters but the
fed yin and the other top regime
loyalists were basically going to be an
inherent part of this insurgency no
matter what and as rich has said you're
going to have a tough mission therefore
to some extent no matter what now i
think i think rich is correct this would
have been tough but what michael and
mick have argued now is we actually
could have gotten a lot of these fedeen
before we even uh
marched on baghdad before we completed
the war or before they had a chance to
flee the south perhaps that's the most
important point and if we had had
follow-on forces of sufficient number uh
and strength in order to follow up and
exploit our opportunities we we wouldn't
have had to make this choice which
turned out to be a hobbsian choice
between continuing the drive to baghdad
and letting these forces stay uh largely
in place except for the ones we took out
in the course of just moving through the
key passes and so uh i think it would
have been tough to foresee this uh it
would have been tough to know that
fedeen were going to fight this way i
think mix essentially acknowledged this
it would have been tough to have good
enough intelligence
to to have this all in the battle plan
in advance but if we had had more
capacity more people on the ground we
could have actually devoted some of the
some of the units the first cav or the
fourth id or others to essentially
taking out the rest of the fedeen to the
extent possible in the south at the same
time as the third infantry division and
the marines kept on moving to baghdad
and perhaps half of that uh who knows
what number but maybe half of that
fedeen element could have been destroyed
in place
if that had been true there was even
more of an opportunity to squelch this
civil uh the civil unrest in this
insurgency in the early months than i
myself had appreciated before what i
think would have been very hard to do
again because the intelligence would
have had to be exquisite or you would
have had to been quick on your feet and
reacting very well but we do have very
good officers in the us military who are
good at thinking on their feet and i
think they had the capability and the
capacity to do some of this without
having to sacrifice the quick drive on
baghdad in order to do so they might
have been somewhat successful so i've
unfortunately become uh even more
critical of the war plan after reading
the parts of the book i've gotten
through because it strikes me that of
those three big groups that make up the
insurgency today
the the core saddam loyalists actually
might have been in a place we could have
more easily targeted them at a moment in
time and we didn't do it uh and and
therefore instead of having to fight two
or three thousand of them to make up a
number we have we have had to fight
seven to ten thousand of them uh and
that number plus all the fence sitters
and the jihadists has allowed this
insurgency to just plateau at a fairly
high level of violent effectiveness uh
one sentence on the next chapter of the
book of kurt i would simply say they
published the book at exactly the right
time because the next year is going to
be more of the same it's just going to
be the iraqis hopefully having more of
the responsibility to win this than we
but our responsibilities are obviously
going to remain quite robust for a long
time so it was a perfect moment to
publish because um i think the the the
next couple of chapters of the next
couple of books written are not going to
look that much different than what we're
reading in the newspapers right now
thanks michael if i could ask some folks
that like to ask questions please
approach the microphones we'll take a
couple and then we'll go to book signing
while you're gathering yourself at the
mic at the microphone let me ask joe
train michael gordon one specific
question i have to say
i went back and read the opening part of
the commanders and it was striking about
how you describe this generation of
military officers that had survived
vietnam that had arrived on the scene
and that put their bold mark on this war
plan and when i read that and i looked
at this book i wondered if you debated
with yourselves about calling this
rather than cobra ii
uh the civilians war in in contrast with
uh uh the commanders or the generals uh
war given the dramatic role frankly and
i would say overriding role that a
number of powerful determined decisive
uh civilian leaders played in the
formulation execution of the military
strategy
let me address that from somewhat
a different angle
if i were about to
write another book
after having done the generals war
and this book and having
um 40 years of service in the marines
i'm not about to write that book because
my wife would be guilty of justified
homicide
but i think i would
look at what has happened to the
american military leadership
elliot cohen of course did a book and
talking about you know civil military
relations with case studies
but i think we have to look at this
the u.s military was deficient the
senior leadership in this war they did
not push back hard enough there is the
culture within the us military to make
your case before your boss
and when he makes a decision you say aye
aye sir and you go out and do the best
you can to carry it out
i think i think that's dodging a
responsibility
and i think that we have to take a
harder look at what we expect of our
military
the military had a pretty good read on
this whole situation from start to
finish
and having gone through two and a half
years of research and study and
discussion
on this
i think the military the solution or the
the result of this war
uh regardless of the legitimacy of going
into it would have been a lot better
but they didn't
they didn't do that there are all sorts
of reasons for that but you have to say
yourself you know they disorder to
defend the constitution they have a
responsibility there is civilian
leadership but something is now lacking
within the u.s military
whether it's the result of the
the defense reorganization act of 1986
the goldwater nichols act which kind of
emasculated the the corporate wisdom of
the joint chiefs of staff whether it's
that or whether it's the business of you
can't get selected for senior rank or
particularly service chief or or
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
unless you're a team player i don't know
but there's something fundamentally
wrong
and if we don't take a hard look at it
and correct the military culture within
the
within the
the the constitutional obligations that
they have
then i think we're going to have trouble
down the pike again this is a classic
case of the military being ignored and
the military not standing up
sufficiently and the end result is what
we saw we had a pre this precursor of
this
also existed in the vietnamese war
military leadership and its
responsibility
is more than a process and more than an
organization chart
a lot depends upon the blokes that are
in that chart
and i'm not so sure
that we have
a sufficiently
robust system to ensure
that the genius that exists within the
military is allowed to express itself
let's take both questions and then we're
going to unfortunately cut that off so
that we can actually get down to
business at hand which is to sell books
so if i could ask both of you to present
a quick question to anyone on the panel
and then we'll
return to hors d'oeuvres and drinks
thank you uh
national studies um i want to follow up
on this because i think this is really
the central theme here that we need to
work on
if intelligence was the shortcoming
getting us into the war
the civil military relations was the
fundamental shortcoming
as we entered into it and going forward
and i want you to talk about the lessons
learned we really hear about the
concentration of power with the
secretary we hear about the
perhaps the lack of influence by the nsc
um
what do we learn from the civil military
relations
that you can talk about how do we get it
right going forward because really this
is fundamental to our ability to
prosecute military actions in the future
and i don't think it general general i
don't think it's just the military side
that needs questioning so i'm interested
in your comments on that
yes
hi james rosen mclashy newspapers i just
wondered if um if we could look try to
look forward
a little bit
and
if two or three of you could see
could say where do you think we're going
are things as bleak as
they sometimes
appear
and can
president bush's vision
of the future be be salvaged
quick answers from each of you michael
um
well i on the civil military um
front um
obviously i think that um this is i
agree with the comment earlier that the
defense department had an undue degree
of influence and responsibility it was
but it was president bush who decided to
give
responsibility for the post-war
to secretary rumsfeld and actually
signed a directive to that purpose so
this was a conscious decision by the
senior
commander-in-chief
to organize events this way i don't
think
we we should forget that rumsfeld didn't
steal the post-war responsibility was
given that by the president
there were military officials who were
given
a lot of authority in the war and made
their views known but in in the case of
general franks he pretty much accepted
the paradigm that rumsfeld laid out
which is that
um transformation you know that you
could get in and out quickly and it was
on his advice that plans to drop
drawn up to withdraw most of the forces
by september and president bush went on
an aircraft carrier and declared an end
to major combat operations so it wasn't
a voice that was stifled it was um
a voice that was uh kind of um
it was heard but it was within you know
the accepted paradigm i'm not sure i
have
i i think that you know i guess uh two
thoughts i have is that um you know in
his exit interview and we have this in
the book on page 39 because i had to
look it up
is in his exit interview with president
bush
secretary of state colin powell told the
president that the national security
process was broken and dysfunctional and
i think there are any number of examples
in that and i think that the people who
i don't think it's impossible to fix i
think it's rather easy thing to fix
there just has to be the will to fix it
and
that means you have to include different
perspectives within your administration
and if you look at the way this
administration i'm not trying to take a
political stand but the one person who
had reservations about this war and
cautioned about it to a certain extent
is not a member the senior level is not
a member of this administration
secretary powell and the people who have
been retained by the administration the
people who are with the program i think
it's an easy thing to fix if there's a
will to fix it at the top as for the
future of iraq that's beyond the scope
of the book and i don't have any great
insight into it but i do feel that at
this stage it's more of a political
depends more on the internal politics of
iraq and sol
may khalilzad's efforts to forge an
internal concession than any any
military uh solution i think the you
know the era of the military solution is
long past
general you get the last word i'd like
to address the first question because
when in my previous remarks i was
talking just about the military but the
question we have a very dysfunctional
system here we operate under the
national security act which was
basically an act was put up in 1947 to
deal with the soviet uh peer competitive
threat and it focused on the military
and it focused on on intelligence but
the world that we we deal with today is
entirely different but we the national
security act although it's been amended
is not amenable to it now there's
somebody here in the audience michelle
florinoy that is far more knowledgeable
on this subject than i am but we have to
we have to be able to better integrate
the interagency process there's a lot of
lip service paid to it but it just
doesn't happen and when the push comes
to shove
the problem dumps on the military for
the military solution and they're not
always the best prepared to do with it
so my basic my basic recommendation is
that we go back and write a new national
security act which would take into the
fact that the world that we live in
today is far different than the world we
lived in in 1947.
thank you all very much
let me ask you yes let's
i know i speak for general trainer and
michael gordon uh how grateful they both
are for you turning out for this big
launch please stay and wish them both
well